mais jean yves le drian il porte sur ses
épaules le lourd bilan de françois
hollande s'est battus parfois pour être
très honnête il s'est battu parfois pour
avoir un budget qui soit moins à la
baisse que ce que voulaient bercy il
n'en reste pas moins que d'abord qui n'a
pas réussi à obtenir ces budgets pour la
défense et secundo qu'il sait qu'il est
solidaire de la politique et qui lisent
solidaire jusqu'au bout de la politique
d'action d'une église de la défense et
si c'est aujourd'hui pourrait rejoindre
emmanuel mais c'est tout de même
extraordinaire de voir un certain nombre
de personnes nous dire aujourd'hui que
la candidature de monsieur macron va
rénover la vie politique au moment où il
est soutenu par tous ceux qui ont fait
cette vie politique
elles sont caractérisées par ses échecs
dramatique mais ça veut dire une seule
chose ça veut dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre de gens autour françois hollande
qui essaye de se sauver et de sauver les
places et les prêts bay les prébendes et
c'est aussi une deuxième réalité qu'il
faut constater c'est que monsieur macron
incarnent en fait la continuité la même
politique que monsieur hollande est
d'ailleurs on le voit bien sur
l'immigration dit d'abord sur l'union
européenne est d'accord sur le modèle
économique il est 9h à 16h à peu près
tous les sujets